I want to buy a house where I can make
memories in every room plant the garden
in my backyard and watch the flowers
bloom it will be big but not so big the
guests would get lost it will be nice
but not so nice that everybody whispers
what it cost it will have gorgeous views
but being hired doesn't mean superior
I've learned not to judge a house by
what's on the exterior it's what's on
the interior and I don't mean design
because a house is not a home unless the
people are aligned I used to want a
mansion I thought that bring me joy I
went and bought a lot of [ __ ] that I had
no time to enjoy I was working for a
living but it wasn't working because I
wasn't living in a life without living
is unfulfilled filling up the empty
space with all the things that I was
getting yet I could never get enough or
give enough to be enough and that was
constantly upsetting value is a tricky
thing is it something that we own or is
it something that we bring experiences
are priceless and they don't cost a
thing because once you make your mind up
you can accomplish anything
even if it seemed impossible impossible
is possible we take for granted that
defying gravity is illogical intend what
you desire and your will will be
unstoppable
see hope can be despair in disguise so
instead I decide then I watch as reality
real lines after all what is time if
it's different in a different place
we're all in one place floating out in
outer space they'll never bottle time
you can't buy anymore
and if you could it be sold out at every
corner store so lately I've been
thinking what if less is really more if
my mortality is what I'm really living
for I want to slide in socks across
Italian marble floor
I want imported art to fill up every
corridor I want my kids to use my bed
like it's their trampoline to walk on
top of my couch like it's their balance
be I want to use my things so they
aren't using me after all the most
important things in life are free
we only borrow land we only borrow time
we only borrow love but you can borrow
mine my house is your house stay over
any time if you're a friend you'll have
a permanent vacancy son community is
what our culture is lacking we pretend
to be connected but mostly it's just
unscripted acting we isolate ourselves
and hide from our emotions then pack our
schedules as an excuse to stay in motion
I'm living by the beach and yet I never
see the ocean because it's always out of
reach in the midst of my commotion god
forbid I'd have to sit alone without
distraction it's hard to notice thoughts
when I'm constantly in action no matter
what your status is that isn't
satisfaction so I don't only care what
you do I care that you're doing it with
passion that's why we all should share
our gifts and cultivate compassion
because the fastest way to bliss is
through a meaningful interaction and
since I'm not even sure that we exist
I've started asking if this world
the form is merely the illusion of
attachment if I could let it all go my
roof would be the Stars my floor would
be the earth my doors would be ajar my
walls would be the wind my seat would be
a stone my bed would be the clouds and
my heart would be my home but since I
want a family and I don't live this life
alone I'm gonna buy a house where I can
make memories in every room